the story isn't the rankings because you
can pretty much guess the outcome
it's going to be the guy who freed the
slaves a republican
in case everyone forgot feel free to
remind the mob as they tear down his
statue
and of course barack obama is near the
top although he wasn't number one which
clearly makes this entire survey
racist in fact including other
presidents on this list
who are all white is disgusting
they should have made the whole list
obama
but the story isn't the ranking it's the
coverage of the ranking
we've had a lot of presidents at least
15 kat but the media only cared about
one politico's headline trump debuts at
41st in c-span rankings
cnn's headline trump is one of history's
worst president
survey says sounds like cnn's ripping
off family feud again
from business insider historians rank
trump among worst presidents in history
usa today historians rank trump near the
bottom u.s
news also says trump debuts near the
bottom of the survey
and cnn double dips because it's trump
presidential historian says
trump should not be happy with this yeah
because
the negative opinion of professors
matters to the most famous person on
earth
melania those men with the pipes don't
like me fetch me the
lexapro from the yacht that's a terrible
impression by the way
their slate what it takes to be a worse
president than trump
and finally the washington post
historians just ranked the president
trump wasn't last so you know what this
reminds me of
when some girl just broke up with your
best friend and while your friend keeps
saying how relieved that it's over and
she's gone he still can't
stop talking about her he won't shut up
about her that's the media
they're heart sick because the bad boy
who gave them the most attention
isn't around to stoke that passion
anymore
you know once you've fried your taste
buds with flamin hot cheetos
you can't switch back to creamed corn
that's what joe has for breakfast and
lunch
and dinner because it's creamed
eat it sometimes through a straw now
none of the headlines even mentioned the
winner
nothing matters except for trump it
doesn't mean border on obsession
it is an obsession the calvin klein
fragrance for a media who
just can't let go and it manifests
itself in hilarious ways like those
headlines
but also in vindictive ways manhattan
d.a cy vance punctuated his long-running
investigation into the trump
organization
with indictments take a look the charges
could lay the groundwork for the next
steps in the wider investigation
which will focus on mr trump the way the
times is reporting this tonight it
sounds like
that's what's next with a focus on mr
trump himself
never seen anything like this a former
president's family business and its
chief financial officer charged with a
15-year alleged tax scheme
most troubling for the former president
isn't what's in these pages
it's that this story reads like it's
just one chapter
and there could be more to come just one
chapter like your brother's
book you can't be talking about
anything right now pal oh god they're so
excited
tick tick boom it happened finally it's
worse than watergate where's that guy
everyone's going to jail but uh did you
see the charges
yeah after pouring over years of tax
records all they got was an alleged
failure to pay taxes on corporate perks
something that
would have been settled with a fine this
charge is the tax equivalent of tearing
the tag off a mattress
but it's trump so they pulled out all
the stops
and the handcuffs the prosecutors made a
show of handcuffing the company cfo some
old guy
and walking him down a hall crowded with
reporters how classy
so political enemies get the perp walk
while violent criminals get a quicker
release
than hunter biden logging on to pornhub
i've never heard of that place if you
run a company
and on the government's radar you should
worry a little this was obviously a
political inquisition not a criminal one
a revenge fantasy playing out to justify
the years and resources devoted to this
case as stalin's head of secret police
said
show me the man and i'll show you the
crime so they put some old
guy in cuffs because it's trump it might
seem like a small thing a tax case at
nyc
but it's just another example of how
trump derangement poisoned so many
things and hurts so many people
you have an entire party rejecting law
and order because trump was for it
the result an explosion in crime and
death you have an entire party rejecting
practical solutions on the border
because trump was for those solutions
result border chaos and children being
abandoned
you have an entire party in media
mocking anything trump said about kova
the result
china escapes culpability if trump
promoted oxygen
they'd hold their breath until they
ended up brain dead
which is perfect for hosting a show on
cnn
it's an interesting phenomenon watching
people inflict pain on their own country
because trump reminds them of their
daddy who didn't love them
which is why the survey deeply comforts
the media as they wonder if orange
godzilla ever thinks of them
as much as they think of him he doesn't
because that would be impossible
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guest
she's becoming a household name that no
one can spell
correctly fox news headlines 24
7 reporter carly shipkiss
he's so deep undercover he's not even
here tonight
former city officer brian dean rice
he always sounds like he's telling his
mom he got detention
comedian joe mackey
he's like apollo 13. lots of things go
wrong but nobody died
last year's contributor cat tim
i got to go to you first joe because uh
you are quote
rocking the uh members only are you
hoping to bring it back
uh it never went out of style if i
weren't
really this is i just keep the clothes
and hopefully in a couple of decades
they come back around
it hasn't yet oh but you still look
great
thank you thank you yes yes and i'm
allowed to say that to men
sometimes i say it too much anyway why
are you showing cat
so joe now that i'm just talking to you
let's get this over with what's your
take on this presidential
survey uh it must be difficult for cnn
to cover this because if something's
ranked 41st
that would be an improvement to their
ratings
roasted
it makes no sense to me that a historian
would rank a president that just
finished being president because there
hasn't been history
yet yes you could say that
clinton had fairly smooth sailing
but then 20 years later there's a
pandemic
yeah and our free trade agreements have
left us in a situation where we can't
make masks yeah so you have to have some
history first before you
rank history that's that's an
interesting point about the masks
yeah i'm pretty smart
the jacket gave it away exactly that is
a smart
jacket you know what that what is a
member's only jacket i
love that i don't know i don't know do
you know cat
no yeah we are being millennium shamed
oh please i don't mean to shave you yes
yes yes
i think it's nice you do you so you
don't know what a member's only jacket
is
brian can you explain what are members
only jeffy i can't i was trying to be
quiet so no one would call it
i don't know a lot about jackets just in
general
yeah you know what then you just stay
out of it little lady
you got me into it carly what is your
take on this
survey well um do you wanna know who
came in last yes please tell me
everything
james buchanan and he was the president
who uh failed to prevent the civil war
so
these historians think that president
trump is almost as bad as the guy
who could have freed slaves but didn't
and i think this actually presents um
this is an example of a greater problem
in our country and it's that
historians and um academics are so
liberal and they're the ones that write
the history books and they're the ones
that are in the classroom so
history is really going to be forever
taught through a partisan lens in it
and it used to not be like that so all
the good things that president trump did
abraham accords the destruction of isis
economic boom that's never going to be
taught it's just going to be
uh january 6th and impeachment yeah and
that's it yeah that's exactly right
january 6th is going to be for is going
to be as
bigger and bigger and bigger meanwhile
what was the name of the operation that
got us the vaccines
um thank you thank you you're welcome
thank god you got it i was like
what was it called yeah so it's almost
like that weird pop quiz on tucker that
no one likes
anyway i'm kidding i'm kidding it's just
that they fix the answers when i'm on
and i don't like that
that's great all right brian welcome to
the show thank you sir yes what did you
make
of the are you uh are you a history buff
were you interested in the survey
well not after the survey because bill
clinton actually beat out ulysses s
grant
yeah which makes a lot of sense because
ulysses has grant of course for those of
us who remember our fifth grade uh
history and or looked at wikipedia just
before we came on the show
he defeated of course the south and he
was actually a pretty fantastic
president he
he was a pretty uh good man of a
thoughtful character
who of course lost out to bill clinton
who of course gave us monica lewinsky
most of his friends died
at some point if he crossed him and then
hillary of course yes yeah so you know i
i think what this shows building on what
was just mentioned
is that our historians are disconnected
from true history yeah and instead uh
they are falling into this academia trap
and i guarantee if you actually ask the
140 some odd people historians who were
quizzed about what they thought how many
of those folks are either left or left
leaning
and or belief in things like critical
race through et cetera i'd love to know
a little bit more about that yeah i
would say that i mean the surveys
usually say it's almost like
90 something percent that everybody in
academia is far left
yeah i mean this survey it ranked trump
in terms of you know pursuing equality
for all
lower than several presidents that own
slaves
that's awful yeah i was kind of like i
don't i don't know if i should take this
seriously plus they
kind of always you know the greatest
president of all time who
calvin cool of course are you kidding me
he said that the major source of safety
for the government for
for the president to know that he's not
a great man
and he governed accordingly he used his
position as president to actually
devalue the government like almost no
regulatory state
you know super low taxes
non-interventionism
plus he was hot great campaign slogan
keep it cool with coolidge oh that he
might have been the first person to use
the phrase cool
in that vernacular right i just made
that up i have no idea if
it's where
and we have the ombudsman today and he's
going to humiliate me for falling for
that
oh to me never have them on the show
again i'm not entirely sure that i can
tell if someone's hot or not
well i was going to say something crude
but you know what out of character
i'm just going to think it hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else